c'est non non
[Musique]
chaque année au coeur de l'automne merci
depuis le début des temps et
probablement jusqu'à la fin du monde
une famille entière d'imbéciles et
décimé par les champignons bin ouais les
champignons je connais et cela malgré
les remarques réitéré des autorités
médicales les plus compétentes et des
sommités mycologique les moins farfelues
voilà les champignons je connais c'est
pourquoi afin d'éviter une mort
grotesque
nous ne devons jamais allés nous
promener dans les bois sans un conte un
champignon voici un conte un champignon
voilà les champignons je connais au
moindre doute de votre part le conte un
champignon se fera une joie de goûter à
votre place le champignon suspect
lui les champignons il connaissait
etonnant non
[Musique]
fait étonnant non